österreich wählt und ich bin dabei aber
wenn man hier spaß haben will dann kennt
man natürlich nicht als lügen presse
dann geht man als alternatives fernsehen
deutschland
nur 16 prozent für unsere freunde von
der fpö aber dafür ist die offizielle
wahl party immerhin auf dem prater
nur leider nicht hinter geisterbahn wir
sind hdtv und wir haben ja die
landtagswahl in thüringen jetzt im
oktober soll es ja noch haben wir sie
nicht geworden
dort sie mir macht ein gutes werk wir
sind vom alternativen fernsehen
deutschland wir haben in thüringen die
landtagswahl haben sie vielleicht ein
tipp dass bei uns der absturz vielleicht
nicht kommen sondern eher ein sieg
erfolgt keine urlaub in ibiza das hätte
er mal hc strache sagen sollen und
apropos jetzt treffe ich straches haus
und hof sänger werner otti von ihm sind
bekannte hits wie
[Musik]
aber ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen dass
die alv dem ort wo ich schaue mir auch
vielen den deutschen bundestag an weil
mir das einfach interessiert und wieder
als die frau weigel muss ich sagen
die fährt schon ein programm äußert da
bleibt kein auge trocken
für die österreich erfolgt also wurde
hat sich strache doch eine falle gelockt
am ende ja absolut das war ja das wurde
über monate vorbereitet trainiert er
komplett inszeniert perfekt man sieht
dass ibiza bietet man kennt nur sechs
minuten davon man kennt den rest nicht
dass wir doch nicht herausgegeben einer
hatte sogar gesagt dass er das auch die
getränke dass die substanzen waren zb
das hat einmal gesagt er an gewicht
diese leute ausgebildet hat im verhör wo
er 24 werk sagt dass da flüssiges kokain
in dem wodka noch drin
richtig ja es gibt substanzen da sagst
du alles alles jetzt wieder eine woche
vor der wahl natürlich wieder neue
sogenannte skandale die nicht mal wieso
sind sondern mit den spesen von hc
strache oder reine spekulation ja aber
jetzt geht's erst mal so was außer
spesen nix gewesen
na ja lustig nicht mehr mithalten
geburtstag
wir wollten unseren spitzenkandidaten in
thüringen auch mal grussbotschaften aus
österreich aufnehmen viel glück in den
wahlkampf könnten sie vielleicht mal in
die kamera lieber bernd hocke ja lieber
bernd für den wahlkampf in thüringen
unter bern
machen wir das verwendete typ dafür
glaube an unser slogan heißt bernd bernd
bernd bernd bernd haben die fdp in
dieser situation helfen dass wir
vielleicht den anschluss österreichs
fordern
das wollen wir lieber nicht die
bundesrepublik deutschland ist uns viel
zu regeneriert und zu dekadent um so
etwas würde den anschluss zu wollen ich
habe eine internationale studie gelesen
da heißt deutschland ist 2035 bis 2050
kippte gesellschaft in deutschland denn
die muslime haben auch kann man noch was
kinder und der deutschen um 1,2 an 80
kinder und das wird irgendwann ja und
dann wird sogar aber dann gibt es eigene
parteien und dann fahr los also muss die
auf der vollständig den sieg erringen
wird das vorher noch gelingt deutschland
und österreich allein historisch stehen
wir ja immer zusammen ich hoffe dass das
so bleiben wird wird die zeit wird auch
wiederkommen vielleicht ich denke schon
ja auf jeden fall andererseits muss ich
auch sagen ich habe hier mal ein wiener
schnitzel gegessen unternehmen so dass
es auch ziemlich schlecht also das ist
hier schon besser erlebt das beste
schnitzel wiener schnitzel in münchen
geht
es ist ja jetzt schon fast
vaterlandsverräter in der fpö also ich
fasse es nicht aber das war wirklich
vorzüglich über die haupt irgendwas
reingetan diese pannier wahnsinn
flüssiges kokain ja den hut bringen
könnte
[Musik]
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok wo geht's denn hier raus
scheiße